l'aventure commence whoa allez vous
prêt à faire ça je sais que vous étiez donc
nous y sommes je suis de retour je suis ravi de
faire une autre science-fiction il s'agit
de tout je suis l'un de ces
réalisateurs qui vient du tout  à propos de
tout ce que l'école je pense qu'ils veulent que
nous venions combattre le monde a été
fait par wrigley et commencer large et suivre
cela ne s'améliore pas vraiment quand
il s'agit de diriger une espèce supérieure
sans aucun doute il a une vision très claire il le
veut  pour être vrai, c'est cette corde
niggas voyez-vous cette entreprise ative nous pouvons
marcher sur un plateau
incroyable
et avons vraiment Scott vous diriger
Ridley a été génial à couper le souffle moi je
veux dire dans tous les départements il est au top
de son jeu on y va  il a juste besoin que
vous soyez aussi réel que possible il s'occupe vraiment de
tout le reste et il ne
meurt pas Dieu merci il
approfondit constamment il a la
vision et l'action les plus extraordinaires Ridley
Scott veut repousser les limites aussi
loin qu'il le peut  Il  Rust Ridley à cent pour cent,
il est incroyable, il est mon directeur de fantasy